France is the heaviest of the alkaline metals,
at least until element 119 is synthesized.
It also has the biggest datum of any element in the whole
periodic table. Now some of you may have seen on YouTube,
there are videos that pretend to be huge explosions of
Francine,
and I'm never quite sure whether I should be really pleased about this because
it shows that people are using the periodic table in the right way.
And deducing that France seems should be really very reactive or whether
I should be tearing out my hair because the videos are
fake and they're chemically wrong.
But most of all, they miss the really exciting part about him,
which is the really moving story about Margaret Perry,
the woman who discovered France him at the beginning of the
20th century, it was obvious that they ought to be an element,
but the bottom of the alkaline metals.
And so lots of people were looking for it. The American professor,
Fred Alison in Alabama,
the one who thought he discovered element 85 also thought that he
discovered element 87,
but it turned out that his method that he was using,
which is quite complicated.
So I went to explain it now with fundamentally flawed,
it was wrong and he wasn't measuring anything except something
psychological in his mind.
It was realized fairly early on that
element,
87 could be made from element
89 actinium by emission of an
alpha particle. An alpha particle is two protons and two neutrons.
So if you take two away from 89, you get 87.
And the problem was that actinium is quite a rare element and was very difficult
to get hold of a sample.
It had been discovered by Andre TBN around about
1900, and he was working in the same Institute as Marie Curie.
And in 1929, a young woman, Margaret Perry,
went to the lab and started as a lab assistant with Marie Curie.
And she was put to purifying actinium you would begin with
literally tons of impure or probably
uranium. And then you would gradually boil it up,
dissolve it,
extract material until you ended up with just a few
milligrams of the material you wanted.
The other problem was that nobody realized how dangerous radioactivity
was.
So they were all working in the lab with very few precautions.
The upshot of this was that Margaret Perry became a real
expert in handling actinium and separating it four years after
she started Madame Curie died.
She started working simultaneously for a [inaudible]
the professor who had discovered actinium and also married to
his daughter,
Irin [inaudible] for some completely unknown reason.
These two people didn't realize they were both directing the work of the same
person.
The aim was to get the purest possible sample of actinium
and then measure the radioactivity coming from it.
The way the acting Liam decays is entirely due to the physics of the
nucleus. The reason for purifying it is to get rid of all the other radioactive
impurities,
which might send out signals that would completely mask the effect you were
looking for.
So what Margaret packer observed was when she took a
really pure solution of actinium and measured the radioactivity
very rapidly for the first two hours,
the radioactivity of the solution increased.
And then it came approximately constant.
And so she did use that.
What was happening was that the acting was decaying to form
a new element,
which itself was decaying and giving out much stronger radiation.
The reason you sold this buildup was because material went into
solution and you got to a stage where it was being formed at the same rates as
which it was decaying.
She also discovered that this radioactivity could be precipitated by
adding cesium salt and then precipitating the cesium sold as
the perchlorate Caesium and element 87 should have
similar chemical properties. So you expect them to precipitate together.
Once it precipitated you could show that the precipitate was radioactive rather
than the solution. And the half-life was about 21 minutes.
So you had to work really fast.
The upshot was that she had discovered element 87
in 1939.
She published her paper on element 87
derived from actinium.
Now there was a really exciting and interesting situation.
Margaret was an lab assistant.
She had no chemical qualifications apart from basic
training, but she had enough material for a doctorate,
possibly even for a big prize,
but she couldn't submit this material for a doctorate because he didn't have a
chemistry degree.
What happened was that she was allowed to go and study during the second world
war to get the necessary certificates,
to allow us to submit her main discovery for a doctoral thesis.
Now, the interesting thing about this paper is that there is only one
author, Margaret Peggy.
And there's the name here of [inaudible] the person who actually
submitted this paper to the journal on her behalf. What's interesting,
neither of the two professors have their names on the papers.
And apparently after the discovery had been made,
they discovered that Margaret was,
as it were double timing them and working with both of them.
And neither of them could agree whose names should go on the paper.
And eventually they decided that she should publish just alone.
It was probably a misunderstanding and perhaps a
reflection of the way that lab assistants were treated.
And they actually asked her who she was working for.
They were both ordering her about now in 1946,
when she submitted her thesis,
she was asked what name she wanted for the elements.
And she suggested that she should call it Catchum CA
T R U M because she believed that being at the
bottom of the periodic table,
it would form ion a positive iron more easily than any other
elements. However, Madame Curie,
his daughter who spoke English said,
she thought it was a bad name because English speakers would think it was
something to do with cats, the furry animals,
therefore it wasn't appropriate for name of an element.
So instead the second choice was Francine named after France,
originally with the symbol F a,
but then this was changed at fr in fact,
Seaborg wrote to Margaret Perry to ask, which was the correct symbol.
And she answered fr after her doctorate,
she had quite a impressive career.
She was made a professor of chemistry and she was also elected as the
first woman to the academic decisions,
the French Academy of sciences,
the first woman since the 17th century.
So it was really quite a triumph, but sadly,
because of her exposure to all these radioactive elements,
as she got older,
she developed chronic radiation sickness and
problems. So towards the end of her life,
when she was really keen to do more research into France,
SIM her health deteriorated and she died quite young in
1975.
But what's exciting is that research is continuing and fancying
people. Now,
consensus size friends assume in accelerators by the method of taking a light
atom and a heavy one. In this case, the light item is oxygen atomic,
number eight and gold atomic number 79,
eight plus 79 makes 87. So for example,
there has been an interesting paper that was published in 2005
on the relative rates of extraction of Francine and cesium from
solution. And even if you have just a tiny amount of Francine,
because it's radioactive,
you can follow the process very easily because modern radiation
detectors can detect even a few atoms.
I think from the point of view, periodic videos,
the most interesting fact is that people have measured the ionization
energy of Francine.
That's the energy required to remove one electron to make France
SIM plus, this is the reaction that occurs when you put the metal in water,
it shows just how reactive the iron.
Holy crap.
Most surprisingly the amount of energy to remove the electron from
Francine is slightly greater than required to remove it from
cesium.
So Caesium is actually a bit more reactive than Francine.
The difference is not very great in principle.
This is quite surprising because you would think that the bigger the atom,
the further the electron will be away and therefore the easier it is to remove
it.
And we've seen this in our videos when we've compared the reactivity of lithium,
which is really small with sodium potassium, rubidium, and cesium,
as the atoms get bigger.
The reason why France SIM doesn't behave as people expect is
due to what to call the relativistic effects.
And we've talked about this in our video about mercury is that as
the atom gets bigger,
the electrons are circulating faster and faster at
speeds that are a fraction of the speed of light,
which affects the mass of the electron.
And therefore makes the atom a bit smaller than one might
expect. Therefore,
the electron is a little closer to the nucleus and is bound a bit more strongly
than it might be. Otherwise if there were not,
these effects pattern is still much bigger than Caesium,
but it's not quite as big as you would expect.
And we're talking about quite a small energy difference between Caesium and, um,
Francine, but it's real.
So this brings me back to the fake videos.
Francine would not react with water more violently than Caesium.
So you shouldn't be surprised that I want to tear my hair out.
Perhaps it's understandable. Even I was wrong on one of our videos. I,
it, that the video of the century would be friends, him and water.
It would be the damp squib of the century.
No one will ever see Fran Sims reacting with water because the so few
atoms. And in fact,
the world record for getting France in Matton's in one
place in one time is 300,000 atoms.
That might sound a lot,
but it is an unimaginable police,
small speck of France SIM. And you wouldn't see anything.
If you drop that into water.
At the moment, the cesium, you can see the lovely gold color it.
Did you believe me? Smelting? I looked at it. Oh yeah. It's very warm.
It's the season's melted.
So we're just going to try and freeze it again.